déjà il s'agit du temps très contrastée
de notre plat pays plus vieux au sud
trop pluvieux
shauna trop chaud direction sud tout
d'abord avec le saint-père quatre jours
de pluie et du côté de millau albi
montauban on a vu le tarn atteindre 6
mètres 20 soit deux mètres de plus que
sa cote dallaire heureusement cette crue
n'a fait aucun blessé et seules quelques
maisons et quelques entreprises ont été
inondées autour de montauban rien à voir
donc avec les terribles inondations de
1930 encore dans toutes les mémoires
à l'époque plus de 1000 maisons avaient
été détruites et les travaux de
reconstruction avait duré plusieurs mois
cette fois ci on a atteint par endroits
des niveaux records de cumuls de pluie
exemple 2 144 litres d'eau au m² à
murat-sur-vèbre soit un cinquième des
pluies de l'année
mais fort heureusement depuis quelques
heures le tarn à commencer sa décrue